fermez les yeux se laissait guider par
ses autres sens et découvrir une
nouvelle façon de pratiquer son sport
c'est le cadeau d'or voir de la
championne Sandrine Martinet aux jeunes
judoka de l'USO un exercice ludique mais
des concertant
ça leur permet de casser un petit peu le
mur la
barre Essonne en situation de handicap
il se souvienne qu'ils ont fait une
initiation que il y a des gens qui font
du judo qui ont handicap visuel mais qui
font quand même du judo
qu'est-ce que ça change alors comme ça
d'avoir un d'avoir le masque et de
l'enlever
[Musique]
d'une falaise c'était vraiment bizarre
parce que du coup sur la technique ça
change quelque chose
oui ça peut être un peu déstabilisant au
départ
à conscience dans la personne avec qui
tu fais judo bah ça va à 39 ans Sandrine
Martinez se lance dans un ultime défi
remporter l'or aux Jeux paralympiques de
Paris 2024 elle avait songé mettre un
terme à sa carrière sportive après des
Jeux de Tokyo mais impossible de finir
sur une deuxième place la dette
malvoyante a finalement décidé de mettre
toutes les chances de son côté auprès du
club de judo du Paris Saint-Germain
[Musique]
je peux pas rester sur sur cet échec
même si c'est une très très belle
médaille d'argent bien évidemment mais
voilà la série on me donne des bonnes
conditions voir de très bonnes
conditions pour m'entraîner c'était
beaucoup plus simple de tout centraliser
sur Paris sur l'INSEP sur l'Institut du
judo et sur un club de la région
parisienne dans une semaine elle
s'envolera pour les championnats du
monde de parageudo à Bakou en
Azerbaïdjan une étape déterminante dans
sa route jusqu'au jeu de Paris et où ces
performances seront suivies aussi bien
au PSG qu'à l'US O
[Applaudissements]